you got a heavy
foot you really get after it behind the
wheel don't you I really do am I making
you nervous not at all Grace and Joe
they are your biggest fans yeah my
daughter Olive she's 11 going on 19 she
told me in bed the other night that she
wanted to start driving motorcycles I'm
really asking for myself because my kids
are going to want to get into all sorts
of like fun things like riding
motorcycles and feeling that freedom
that I felt and I want that for them but
I'm scared as as their mom my mom still
gets probably as nervous as she did 20
years ago you'll learn to accept that
it's what your kid loves doing more than
anything else and that will give you
enough kind of I guess happiness she's
willing to put her fears in the back
seat you and your happiness in the front
seat you articulated that
beautifully is it true that when you had
a crash recently
that you had a split second moment and
you had to decide whether to hit him or
the wall see is that how it went down
yeah I immediately saw where he was on
the track and I was like okay I'm either
going to go into him at like a T-bone
which is not nice or I can just try and
safely crash into the wall your Split
Second decision making means that there
is care and concern for other human life
first that's from Joel and Grace I grew
up in a very like caring affectionate
household family time is really
important well what about you are do you
want to have a family yeah I would like
to why I hesitate with answering it a
little bit is my job I travel so much
that I I would want to be there I guess
like I don't want to miss things growing
up I feel like once my life settles if
it ever does that would be a more
appropriate time a Red Light
confession go in the glove box and pull
out a card and ask yourself a question
what's the craziest thing you have ever
done in a car H oh no I there's things
that I don't want to say um oh those are
the best ones you just you get up to
Mischief as a kid and you might like
throw things out windows I did that once
I littered once out of a car and it was
the one and only time I've ever done it
oh this is
maybe worse than litter it was no you
just no let's just um anyway it's
another red light next question have you
ever been naked in a car yeah me too
yeah I may have got a knock on a window
once were you changing or were you alone
were you with somebody uh I was changing
definitely changing wink
wink all righty um be honest you obey
the speed limit definitely more than
[Laughter]
you I'm excited for you get on that
racetrack and that for reminds me the
bags have flown
everywhere are you going to do what I
think you're going to do why is this
your tradition I ask myself this
question all the time so a bunch of
Aussies were I went there you go that
well that's quite a lot just push that
down and this is really great is this
your first ever shoy it's called a shoy
yeah oh no it's so cute I love
it a bunch of my Aussie mates were doing
it and then I was like I need to do
something in F1 that just makes her feel
a little more relaxed I just thought a
shoy would just kind of lighten the mood
cheers to your race cheers cheers to
Grace and Joe for bringing up such a
beautiful and thoughtful person bring it
in thank
[Music]
you